so a very warm welcome to this
afternoon's panel on the future of
learning I have been asked to present
the panel and I guess also myself my
name is Helga Nowotny I'm the moderator
here I just want to assure you that my
first named Helga has nothing to do with
the storm that play you last two age so
here on my panel we have bread
Samardzija and he has been working for
more than 20 years in information
communication technology industries and
I will leave it at that followed by fam
Fred man who served as vice chancellor
at the University of Gothenburg and
probably is known to most of the people
here in the audience professor of
neurochemistry followed by cal women who
is a professor of physics of the weather
school of education at Stanford
University but who has been extremely
active over many many years in pushing
the envelope of education and that has
also demonstrated what you can achieve
by changing the principles in which you
addict educate physicists and and others
Sookie fee abdul razzaq and short soo
Lee at sorum he is the 4th president of
the International Association of
universities which is a UNESCO based
organization in Paris and last but not
least professor los puros on who is vice
president of Chalmers University and
professor of condensed matter physics
and has been one of the leaders in
getting the European spallation source
to this part of the country and to to
this country but it's a European error
source so this is my panel we are
discussing the future of learning and we
just hit in the same room a other panel
on the future of knowledge and we ended
by the consensus view that the future of
knowledge is very much dependent on
getting the education
system right so we take over from the
previous panel and I turn to you bread
with the first question which is
addressed to the whole panel but i will
start with you and and with cal diamond
what do you see as the major impact that
technology has had will have on the way
how we learn but of course also on the
education system as miserable right
absolutely so yeah I have so my job is
actually training the 120,000 employees
at ericsson across 147 country so I have
quite the challenge and it's interesting
to hear all these things that are coming
that we can apply I want to talk about
the impact of infrastructure that's
coming in next five years that I think
is a game-changer so i have to audiences
i have to train first are all these
really professional employees around the
globe and what I see is a game changer
coming is 5g so let's eat our chief
technology officer said Brad it's just
not another G so 5g should be here in
the next five years just explain it and
if I what he is 5 g when you have your
cell phone and it's the network you call
in to the best you can do today is for
g5g is a hundred times faster so imagine
you download the James Bond movie in
about four three or four seconds which
is amazing but the other thing that's
really cool about it is it's a super
highway and so instead of a little
narrow pipe that we're all fighting to
get through it's a super highway where
we can actually start realizing the
vision of the Internet of Things so
machines talking to machines people
talking to people it's going to enable
all the things that we're predicting the
car don't would it take to become
crowded again how long will be one how
long will it take to become crowded
again crowd it again well we'll see
because actually we do think machines
talking to machines will fill up that
space clay quickly drill quickly the
second audience that I actually care
about is we actually work on the
education for all initiative so you
person people talk about that the United
Nations initiative to make sure all this
underdeveloped countries people get the
right to have education
and most of those people are not
connected so they don't have TV they
don't have phones and somebody mentioned
the great equalizer which is connecting
those underdeveloped companies to the
globe and by 2021 they predict that will
have ninety percent of the world's
population will be connected through
mobile devices so it actually jumps
across all those infrastructure issues
so I think somebody mentioned leveling
the playing field this would level the
playing field allow somebody in Africa
the same access to the MIT courses does
somebody in Boston Massachusetts might
get so I won't go on and on but it just
imagine the possibilities cousin women's
you see the world in a similar light or
no I see you grow and learning as in
technology in a very different light I
mean I I study learning and then what's
effective teaching for achieving that
learning and what we see is what real
meaningful learning is about is quite
different than what technology has been
supporting and and generating people at
you know people making such a big fuss
about it that's about information and
presenting information to people that's
not what real meaningful learning is
meaningful learning is about how to use
that information and how to make
decisions with it and frankly all of our
research I mean every video studies is
says that watching the MIT course where
online you don't really learn anything
from it okay you can get information
government you get that same information
other places and you still won't learn
it it it so learning really requires
very different things and so far
technology hasn't really been used to
support it now can it yes I think it
definitely can but but it really
requires people to start rethinking what
learning is an understanding learning
and effective teaching is quite
different than providing information to
be can you just from your experience
give a few details concretely because
you have studied what learning means I
think it's good for the audience not
just to describe it in
a short way but to give some concrete
examples so when when I say it mean it
comes to them making decisions with it
and so when faced with the situation a
question or a problem you know but if
someone is has learned something mean
evoke they they learned how to tackle
this problem like someone who's you know
an expert in the subject don't have to
be an expert obviously at a low level
but that means asking what is the
information that I should bring to bear
on this problem and and then you know
answering that question correctly
realizing what information they should
use how they should use that information
how they can draw conclusions from it
what decisions should they make on the
basis of that conclusion and you know
that can be in a simple physics problem
of okay you know you give them what you
give them a question that car runs into
a truck and then they they have to work
through and then think about what
concepts would apply how would I decide
how would I justify this is the right
concept to use and then if I apply those
kinds of what would it say about an
answer okay and so you people have to
practice those reasoning and decision
making and information filtering skills
and get feedback on them to guide their
thinking that's kind of what you need
for effective teaching and the result of
the fact it is also what universities
discovered MOOCs is not the solution to
all the problems that university self
with scarcity of teaching scale stuff
for being too expensive etc but I'm
turning now to come fredman what in your
experience does it need to make this
interaction with teacher teachers who
are still teachers facing students and
using the best of the technology what is
your experience in making this happen or
are there other aspects that we still
need to take into account especially
from the view of a vice president of a
university
if I think it's a big difference if we
talk about the school system the primary
and secondary or if we talk about higher
education and as we talked this morning
I mean technology is there and I see
that we can use the information through
technology but that's just information
that is not learning and all the
discussions we have this morning was how
do we make the people is the English
society in all the word capable of
taking this information and making
something into it so I think that what
we will see in the end the higher
education as university is very
important that we continue to have the
technology and the information through
technology as a compliment the most
important thing is that we have students
that are trained that using the
different types of information putting
them into context discuss them to be
critical to be analytical because those
people would be the individuals for the
future and I don't think that we will
have a word I don't think that we can
meet the sustainable development goals
unless that we educate people and that
is not just in the countries we are
living in here it is countries where
Julie is are representing where if I'm
scared if we just sending out technology
we be not have the individuals in those
countries who can respond to what
information get up yeah I'm just wrapped
up with peace I mean what we see in in
in higher education in particular is
there places where technology can really
extend the capabilities of a good
teacher because a good teacher has to be
you know posing questions to students
and then giving them feedback based on
what they know but also what they don't
know or what they think incorrectly that
it there's a lot of ways we see we can
use technology where the teacher can
have a much better sense of the thinking
of you know not just for students at a
time the 40 or 200
students at a time and therefore provide
better guidance immediate feedback to
those students so that's that's one
place where we see that it's very
directly benefit beneficial but it's not
replacing the teacher it's amplifying
the capabilities of teacher I mean
sometimes to stay for a moment within
higher education and also the training
of researchers and I look to learn here
very often it is so important to get
students to ask the right kind of
questions that's much more difficult
then you know teaching them something
that they will just be able to remember
so what is your take on learning scene
from that perspective in relationship
with technology and the use of
technology of course we heard this
morning also that if you have the right
methods and artificial intelligence can
help you sometimes you can increase the
level of learning quite a bit which was
very good fflint and that is of course
used in many different places here but I
think what we are aiming at it our
university is very much to look to Train
also the students in in challenges to
take on the big challenges and to think
independently and also work together and
I think this is for this you have of
course you have you solve or
technologies for various kinds but just
to have a very large challenge like
sustainable transport and that is a big
big challenge for mankind how we will
achieve that and actually put a number
of students last year in a course which
is called challenge lab every day just
gave them this kind of challenge and
some teaching how to approach a big
problem so in this they also get got
access to two
researchers relevant researchers and I
go to access also 22 company leaders and
they will also go to access to
politicians so what the did first was to
try to formulate the problem and they
came from very different disciplines and
the formulated problems and then I went
to all these actors and I try to come
further and further to the problem of
sustainable transport what's the benefit
of dicks well they learn how to
integrate you with a different kind or
knowledge then know how to pose a
problem and they may also learn how to
change the world in the end and the good
thing about students they are not afraid
so they have good ideas they can cross
the borders so they became more or less
some agents for for change and I think
this is what we are looking for today
that we have trained people change young
people that can take on this these
challenges of course there should be a
knowledge base but to do this in the end
of the of the education I think it's
very interesting and stimulating and I
think one way to tackle our challenges
for the future I mean you gave us a good
example of really what one can call
interdisciplinary research mmm and in in
the sense that it is necessary to
formulate a problem together so it's not
someone else formulating the problem and
the others are helping towards helping
to solve it but it's a joint exercise
which is much more demanding than people
can think of at the same time you know
interdisciplinarity has been debated for
decades and there is still the view and
I share this view that universities
still have to teach disciplines because
first you have to know what is a good
question in your own discipline before
you can venture out so this is just an
aside well if I go to this into this
with an area I I was just had an
inauguration of global chances program
at our University and what is that built
on has built on strong disciplinary
research
we need to bring them together from
humanities Social Sciences from
technology and from from medicine they
have to be together so and what I have
seen in through the years is that we
have become more and more disciplinary
and we don't meet other disciplines in
the Indian River see nothing that's a
drawback and that's not good learning
that's not good for the future can
technology help in making these bridges
yes we can because technology is is a
driving force and I think that everyone
wants to be in that if we take the ICT
but if we want to be have people have
students interest of that we have to
bring in humanities and Social Sciences
they want to have the more soft values
and Erickson has also pinpointed this we
cannot just come with technology and
therefore it's so I think that that
could be a common question what is good
technology doing and then we bring
together different disciplines okay I
now would like to turn to sort and I
want to start out with something you
know we have not defined learning here
and that's not our our task but we see
how multi-dimensional the concept of
learning is whether you learn by
yourself whether you learn from a
teacher whether you learn in a group
students learn very much from each other
technology enables you peer learning is
very important and it comes with
technology I clearly but then there is a
tension that I see between learning that
is still very much embedded in a local
context you know there are questions
that come up demands needs the turn up
in a local context that drive the
learner or the learning community and
this is particularly the case in
countries like the ones you represent
and at the same time we have this
tension to you know what happens with
the causes of MIT and Harvard you know
they're all over the place so how do you
bridge this enormous also it's a
cognitive social and economic gap
between the local needs
and what is available at the highest
global level thank you very much i think
it's not only economic episode to a
cultural gap that's the one that
concerns me most for example when you
talk about technology we are very
mindful that if you follow through
technology the way it is now you find
that many languages will die very soon
with English being the dominant language
so to speak other languages will die
because you will not be able to develop
my own language perhaps would be under
threat when the government say you have
to do now science and technology in
English and therefore there's no way to
develop our local language into could
encode a scientific language now when
the language died I think the whole
culture died when a whole culture a
whole nation died what's that one too
for example in Africa where is a special
meaning I cannot be translated in other
language will also die with it and the
whole concept will die with it so there
is a real threat in that particular
sense and we are now coming back to the
whole idea the purpose of learning the
purpose of learning must be the same
whether you're develop of developing
countries and the history i go back to
unesco four pillars of learning learning
to do learning to know learning to live
together and learning to be i think
learning to be is the one that unifies
us together because one we know who we
are in the context of learning together
then i think this whole tension can be
defused if you don't have this then you
will not be able to interact and
interconnect with one another and in
coming from the eastern tradition if you
if we take the word of Confucius he
defines learning as learning is about
being not about having so the whole
purpose of learning is now to educate a
human person rather than an economic
person human capital the way we call it
now and leaves a lot other undesirable
sort of a metaphor or criteria to it so
in this part of the world and our part
of the world we are always taking quote
unquote cue from the developed countries
now I'm often asked are you were lost
and my answer to that is whose well are
you talking about
because my world has a different
connotation of what work class is all
about but yet we are supposed to conform
to a kind of a definition of a world
class including MOOCs my Minister wizard
adversity in the West and learned about
MOOCs the next day he called me out when
are we going to launch our motors you
know we don't even we don't even know
where to start at very fundamentals now
you are putting this on us given the
so-called benchmark that is taken from
from from different parts of the world
that may not be applicable to us so this
whole of this whole notion of attention
i think is very real but we take the
signal from from the north and unless
the north give the right signal then
perhaps people in the South would
probably be just grappling with what is
happening around the world today can I
just ask you you're so pessimistic about
languages I mean I see English taking
over everywhere but I also remember this
was clawed a leg when he was a french
minister son said English is a technical
language and he was French and he knew
what he was talking about so you come
from a country where many people speak
three four five languages so there is
this tradition of multi linguist why are
we so bad in the west of sticking only
to one language I mean you must have
thought about this as a cultural
difference where you are much richer in
terms of understanding and this sort of
ability to reach out when we speak about
interdisciplinarity it's similar you
must be able to understand at least in
the language of another discipline to
form part of the group that buren gets
together in his challenge lab but but
then but it's not but I think that is
now being taken over when we talk about
technical language meaning science and
technology perceive that what you mean
but science and technology cannot exist
without humanity and social science
that's my point of view you know you
cannot be science and technology in
English and ignoring the other
parts of culture which makes science and
technology and therefore in our
association the IAU we're beginning to
recognize the word knowledge as plural
knowledge is in a sense that there is
also knowledge from the indigenous site
the traditional site that we need now
quote unquote to co-create knowledge we
cannot leave it to to to to a certain
group of people to define what knowledge
is we need to sit down and co-create and
these perhaps where the solution is for
the future where you have other people
from different tradition learning
different languages co-creating it so
that it becomes a kind of quote unquote
universal I know whether it is utopian
but I think there were co-creating
languages and cooperate acknowledge it
perhaps a way to go in the future okay
right oh it's just going to say I know
technology's not pick the box I'm in
Africa I watch a MOOC and I'm a PhD but
not everybody can afford a college
education or to come to Sweden or
Harvard or whatever so the comment i
wanted to make is I think I CT and
technology can open up the borders to
things that people don't have access to
and to talk about targeting is that
we're working with Forest Whitaker and
he's training piece developers and
conflict areas so essentially we're
connecting a village that has no TV etc
and training these people local villages
to with basic skills to go out and
create a peaceful environment in areas
that are under strife and one of the
things that we saw to we set up these
little stations locally in this village
and when we went back there were
hundreds of kids outside the village
waiting in line to get on a computer and
take some of these things now they're
starting from scratch and you know
they're not going to be phd's but they
had nothing and so that's what i meant
as some of this infrastructure actually
at least gets them up to bat so to speak
so they have a chance and maybe starts
the bowl of ball rolling to establish
progress in these areas maybe have a
comment hey can I to question one is
basically why is education now getting
more and more expensive nobody even
asked that question i mean III saw in
the US for example there is it there's a
documentary from CA
and Columbia University this is a
deflation rating in the u.s. education
is now one thousand one hundred times
even higher than food and housing a
question is why education is so
commoditized and it becomes so expensive
that is not reachable for the ordinary
people that's a question another thing
we need to solve and then technology
will come in in that kind of a context
we cannot substitute technology when the
price of education wing I and I and
hoping the technology was soft the
problem I don't think it will solve the
problem and second question is basically
this whole idea of technology i'm not
too sure whether you have heard
experiment by dr. Goethe mitra that
talks about a project of a hole in the
wall that he uses a computer just by
lodging this computer in the wall in
very rural sort of india and find that a
student learn on their own without even
having intervention by teachers and he
even managed to show that the student
learning at that particular time is
equivalent to the instruction that was
given in the school and she added one he
added one more thing hiring a
grandmother to cheer the student on you
know you're doing well go ahead and
stuff like that and he fine he found
that the the level of learning increases
even more so this whole idea of
technology that we talked about in the
context of modern technology i have some
reservation on it even it look at
experiment's legs been done investor
good time tre and i think there is
something we need to think about rather
than just surrender the technology the
way it is give it to us yeah Pam I think
Carl yeah let's go in that order go back
to school again I mean when you talk
about different languages when we talk
about different cultures we will be
facing the same thing all around the
world I mean if we look at just at the
city we have a lot of people coming here
from different parts of the world we
have to face the fact or or in school
that we are challenged with people with
different backgrounds who takes new
knowledge in different ways and that
will be have a big demand of the
teachers and teachers are what we are
educating
higher education and we need to bring
them the competence and the knowledge to
handle this and this is not the
situation for this year on the next year
it's a situation for the word for a long
long time and we have to take that
responsibility which we changed the way
how we train campus is well come I
didn't want to correct a couple of
statements to the stage so so first this
idea that sticking the computer in the
wall can do as much as the teachers
local okay so yeah that I think that's
true i mean the restore the measurements
there were pretty crude frankly but what
is really telling you is more about how
the teachers were functioning than the
computer and it just gets back to my
point of you know those teachers are our
have rather limited content knowledge
and they're standing up talking
basically talking textbooks and so
almost anything is as good as that that
doesn't mean that the computer and wall
is providing much educational value the
second thing about the rising cost of
education based on the u.s. numbers ok
but the education is not rising at
anything like that rate this is based on
you know on statements of intuition and
basically it's a shifting of costs
within the system and so it is actually
I'm not going to make a claim as to what
the actual increase in rates are but
it's nothing like the thousand percent
that's so I'll just make that statement
that is a more complicated system and
you know university tuition is going up
because universities are doing more
research student tuition they don't they
hide it but it's actually going to
subsidize that it's it's a mess it's
very common system but it's the reality
is the basic Constitution are not going
up nearly as high as the state but we
also have this opposite between the US
and Europe when you're by and large in
many countries
access to university is completely free
or with very low tuition fees so it's
the state is the community that pays but
it remains within the system someone has
to pay for it yeah and at the US the
pinnacle II the public support has gone
largely gone away and so it's a shifting
of cos it's not a fundamental increase
yeah so did you want to reply to that
your dad we're talking about the future
of learning and and what we haven't been
talking to you through the day so far
what I've heard is we are not talking
about schools or the young people coming
into the universities but what we reform
education because people need training
throughout their working life and I
think that if we talk about technology
in that perspectives we have students
that has another experience and also who
needs to have technology to combine the
meeting between individuals and teachers
and also to get information to handle
where they are sitting so I see that
will be a large part of the population
all over the world that they have to
have be trained throughout life quick
comment on that I it used to be you
learn something whether it was a trade
or something in the University and then
you just leverage that for the rest of
your career and things are changing so
rapidly that you can find your skills
outdated pretty quickly so you kind of
need to see what's coming and the smart
ones are gaining skills all the time
learning all the time as adults and the
ones that don't sometimes they wake up
and they're unemployed and it takes a
huge effort to shift their skill set and
so you'll find an industry that I face
on one hand you people with skills maybe
you don't need as much anymore and you
have a huge vacuum of skills that you
can't get from the universities in
another area and it's sad because a plus
B equals full employment but you don't
that doesn't work out that way I think
the question you know I are we speaking
about schools or higher education we're
speaking about both
the situation is one where you have no
longer clear delineated boundaries in
terms of learning I have a friend in
Paris who does a very interesting
experiments with children from migrant
backgrounds as it's called and he
teaches in schools with motivated
teachers to do very simple experiments
like having a table with ants until you
put a obstacle so that ants can't go
back to the to the hole and the children
are expected to describe so to observe
to describe to analyze what is happening
and then they have a hypothesis you know
why do many ants go to the right side
and not to the left side etc so at the
same time with such a simple experiment
you can teach them how to do research
you observe you describe you have
discipline you analyze your form a
hypothesis so this is something that
costs almost nothing and yet it's
something that you can keep for your
lifetime and I think there are many
examples of these kinds many small
experiments that are being done in
various parts of the world that I think
we need to recognize to encourage we
need to create more spaces for such
experiments that's somehow I feel that
this is crossing the normal boundaries I
mean there's a project I start a number
of years ago that actually has rather
complex interactive simulations online
and what we've seen is that the sort of
things you're talking about are actually
as effective or more effective when done
online because I can essentially yeah do
the equivalent to tailoring the apps to
make it a little easier to follow and so
on and so that's one clear place where
technology can really provide a medium
that that facilitates things that you've
seen work but make it cheap cheaper and
easier for people to get access to yeah
good I
I agree that is low technology things
are really are very important to
stimulate the curiosity and so on so I
think one should really look for that on
the other end I'm since I'm responsible
for the European Asian source then I can
say is that that is perhaps on the other
end and in that case this is also
stimulating the younger generation quite
a lot because they see that this is a
particular thing that can do fantastic
images of atoms and so on and in
material or biomolecules and if they are
really stimulated so I meet people when
i go on train when I play golf just a
few weeks ago as I I met a young guy he
was about 14 years old and he was amazed
are you connected with the ESS and he
told me that he's his teacher he was
having a science update every every week
every week there was a scientist update
what is happening on the science front
in with diverse areas and every week
there was something about the ESS and he
was so stimulated and well I want to
work there but this is something to aim
for its stimulating it's like what we
had the telescope and astronomy is the
similar thing so that's I mean they're
motivated by this there are some
relevance to to find new knowledge and
curiosity so I think this is on the
other end some stimulus but i agree
complete that these simple experiments
are really stimulating the curiosity and
the drive to go forward for new
knowledge I mean what several of you
have been saying is also you know
technology enables an outreach from
science to wider society and we have
movements like citizen science where
people are invited to participate you
know even if it is a relatively low-tech
defined task but nevertheless to feel
part of the process of research and so I
think technology opens up but it also
opens up
the way how we can tackle these grand
challenges and you know we started out
with you speaking about your lab we have
heard about climate change repeatedly
what can be done so in your experience
what would you say are some of the
underused resources the technology has
in getting a wider part of the public of
society engaged in this task where we
need everyone if we want to tackle these
grand challenges I'm interested in your
experience and your comments my point of
view I think technology is certainly
useful but there are conditions attached
to it I think basically it has to be
first of all from from what I've
observed he has to be affordable if it
is affordable then I think it is not
going to be used full too many countries
around the world particularly we heard
how the costs are falling dramatically
yes so this should not be the major
problem any but but still when you talk
about affordability here we are
comparing food on the table and you know
so that that is not a kind of a kind of
different kind of a comparison yeah so
he has to be affordable in that
particular sense and then once is
affordable then I think many countries I
think you might be with me a question of
connectivity for Napoli is it accessible
in a particular and that particular
sensor so there are the conditions that
needs to be met before we believe that
technology will be the solution for the
future my worry is that at least in my
part of the world when we talk about
21st century education the first thing
that comes to mind is technology you
know so everything now is based on
technology and therefore the budget that
you talk about shifted everything goes
the technology textbooks are now no
longer required because you can get it
online but you get it online maybe four
hours in the day after that you don't
have it anymore so this whole idea of
technology being the solution needs to
be clarified that particular sense
other comments mmm well I still think
that even though not all people all
individual can have their technology I
think that the more we can bring out
technology the more we can send out in
this case information about what's going
on and I say technology can illustrate
what's going on in the climate and all
that with scientific basis and have more
people involved in what's going on but
without education of larger populations
of the society there will be no
responders because food on the table is
more important than looking into the sea
youtube somewhere else so I think that
spraying knowledge and giving this out I
think it's a good thing but we also have
to have educated people on all levels
around the world to way to bring us in
to something that take action yeah well
I think the technology is an obvious
asset here let's about climate change
for instance just to sense the planet
Earth and what is happening with climate
and and other things around the world
the globe I think that is very important
that we we have these pictures and they
are visualized and they can be
transmitted and we can use them in the
teaching I think this is tremendously a
powerful that have them and reproduced
as the technology is really important
here and actually we do have a MOOC
course which is course called the
sensing planet Earth which is a really
makes use of this info for for the
general well students we have perhaps
questions from the audience we can take
two or three questions and there is a
microphone so who would like to ask a
question we have one here in the first
row go first where you are and then come
up to the first trophy we cannot hear
you can you stand we cannot hear your
customer Hey yummy alright great
discussion and I wonder if it's not time
to decouple learning from
and academia because right now it's only
discussed on a national level often as
an average compared to other countries
like here in Sweden Pisa is very common
for example but learning must down on a
on a personal individuals and local
level and go from that build from that
context and not from a global more
global anonymous level okay I I think we
touched this tension between the local
and the global and we tried to follow
what you are suggesting but kind well
and the industry level to industry yes
so yes and and lifelong learning again
you know it goes far beyond this is why
I also said you know the lines become
completely blurred between what we do in
school even before school it starts with
kindergarten and it continues across
many many domains there was a question
here in the first row please mmm thank
you my name is Oliver listen I'm an
artist and should you pass by stockholm
i have assured the medina museum right
now but anyway i'm a teacher i'm a
professor at university in berlin and
i'ma at the m50 a job to professor at
the University of Addis Ababa and I've
worked with the exchange between the
tool for quite some years now and we are
actually collaborative on a MOOC
experiment but as I'm an artist and work
in a school and that in in Addis Ababa
means that I'm involved with the art
school but also with the design
industrial design the film school
theatre poetry I mean art in the broader
sense interestingly I was we have been
very focused on achieving you know how
do we prevent the German self-confidence
to somehow colonize I guess is the right
word the sort of unique creativity in
Addis Ababa because the truth is that is
actually not the Germans who are so
colonizing s the desire in Addis Ababa
to take on the technology skills and
they learn skills and so on from germany
so they're very willing to
dubbed where we are trying to promote
you know a local sense of and you
brought up the notion of language a
local language in a sense of form I
wouldn't call it self esteem but you
know it's something very non
quantifiable somehow and this seems to
be a really great challenge that this
school in Addis Ababa is so how should I
say and not fun I mean it's kind of
understandable is so obsessed with
becoming a Western University that we
are you know we meaning me and a few
other collaborators from from one from
each I actually are trying to stimulate
well where does identity and and and you
know the idea of the self actually grow
locally so I'm quite curious about the
sort of the relationship with technology
and you know the local sense of identity
and and in one element in this I don't
think that it's about money i do see a
quantifiable or a strong tendency to
objectify I mean commercialize yes but
objectify knowledge and this I think is
one of the threats there is a great
tendency to seem to suggest that that
success in education is quantifiable so
that is a kind of a question in the
question because I think one of the
challenge is well we don't know what you
are about to learn but you obviously
have to find out in the process of
learning so the success criteria would
be the process rather than the the end
at the end of it maybe you can you can
answer that inspire me how to bring
about Joeckel self-esteem very very good
question to you but I think also to us
yeah thank you can I yes please Oh oui
oui two years ago we run a conference
called decolonizing the universities and
he's coming from 60 academics around the
world precisely to look into this issue
that while university needs to be office
of a same size fit all kind of thing you
know universities evolve in different
cultures in different ways but I guess
the whole issue at the end of the day is
back to the question of what is a bench
that is imposed on us I mean my
university will not be successful until
I am able to equip myself with another
University in the West whole question of
ranking the whole question of league
tables becomes a very complicated issue
alien of it a and therefore until we are
able to emerge with another sort of
paradigm as it were a non-western
paradigm in this particular case then
you will not be able to take this
forward and the students will always
want a Western degree not not an Eastern
League you not even a local degree and
in this particular sense so it is a very
complicated issue depending on what we
define as education s and this is why i
think the initial argument where
education is about the self is about
learning to be and about being rather
than having these are these are some of
perhaps the answer to the larger
question that you have post mm I think
that you're racing something that we're
always talking about those rankings and
we put up criterias and parameters and
with that we will all be the same and it
would be very good to go from this
meeting and say that we stop all these
ranking and see the diversity and the
value of double yesterday around the
world it would be nice but you know as
we know from rankings even if we
criticize them they have an impact as
long as we believe in them but oh she
and i would say that if when it comes
the inequality all those marrow meter or
many of those parameter is not in favor
of which inequality around the world
yeah now we agree and my boss is right
so let me conclude this session and i
would like to come back to the question
you raised about the self esteem and
what we said about being and i think
this is one of the ideas that learning
and education has had not just to impart
skills which are important for the
employer market etc but also something
about the ID
entity and the person and the
personality at the same time I think we
agree something that learning in the
future of learning must cultivate is
creativity and creativity means not to
be mainstream and not to let yourself be
mainstreamed except when it is
absolutely necessary in their functional
ways but you have to go with the
mainstream but otherwise we need
creativity if we want to help to work
towards the solutions of the challenges
we face so thank you very much the
session is gold